she's giving your dad read something
about [ __ ] poppy seed rolls poppy
it was a federal [ __ ] probation for
two and a half years yeah
I ducked all those piss tests see I was
lucky there was no head test you know I
told Rogan one time what I would do I
would get [ __ ] up the night before I
would snort coke till 4:00 in the
morning and then you have to call that
one to get the color and if your color
comes up you got to go pee before six
o'clock and I would drink a bottle of
white vinegar the whole bottle the whole
bottle would Gatorade like a soldier
just drink it soldier I would [ __ ] be
pissing blood but let me tell you
something I don't have a positive [ __ ]
oh did you can't trigger 16 thing a
white vinegar cranberry juice and
Gatorade and it amazing no one came back
positive
then they said you come back with
another one we're gonna [ __ ] throw
you in prison
so I'm uncircumcised so I came up the
next time I went I put pool cleaner in
my dick they move and I [ __ ] held my
helmet the skin like the the [ __ ]
telling like sorry about this a jaw is
dropping and you [ __ ] that's just good
when you're circumcised you can whack
off and if you have a tissue you can
just hold the top and your dick swells
up like a pen like a snake and [ __ ] like
you know the printer oh my god oh he
water swells up like an air balloon and
you just walk around dip it in the
toilet there goes another one you know
eight times I do I just walk off I don't
want to mess I just hold onto the
turtleneck to the commercial comes and I
go to the bathroom drain my little
[ __ ] my little egg white juice but
the third time the second time I put
pool cleaner in there and I still came
like I [ __ ] up the Machine right they
were like we couldn't get a read on you
by that time I was clean you were out no
I was out but you ever think of just not
doing coke tonight though I'm in the
halfway I was like I have fun
that's so the third time I took my dick
pulled it back and I put Drano on that
[ __ ]
well I can't feel the dog I still got
scars from a little drain on my helmet
like it looks like a little bit looks
like the nose of a great lawyer looks
like I got shot with a thousand BB
that [ __ ] burned my dick but that time I
broke the machine - [ __ ] man oh my god I
would use everything I was not let them
they would [ __ ] go crazy they would
send somebody in the bathroom with me
and I would send them one time I made me
piss in a cup and that time I to drain
out the stuff - uh yeah Drano and when I
was when he was doing the paperwork I
put the bow on the desk and you could
see the bottle out of here before that
[ __ ] starts foaming out of here is [ __ ]
when that doctor must open that thing
and that pitch shot out of there he made
a they knew they [ __ ] me but you know
they were fury
they could never get so you're a
straight you're you're full-blown addict
managed oh you take a night off night
thought I was selling coke in the
federal halfway house they had those
feelings like this so I would put the
scale up there and the coke and I
remember weighing the coke and the
[ __ ] coke rocks would go on the floor
and I have to and those little powders
from the thing with you on the carpeting
and the lady came in when they she's
like we gotta get somebody to work on
that because a lot of white stuff coke
all over the [ __ ] floor but you know
you don't [ __ ] with any of that I don't
think we really but there's a week and I
gave up a double space right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]